a bunch of great games I've come out and
are coming out this week and next week
video games the back bye bye summer I'm
Alexa ray Korea is here to tell us all
about until dawn yeah a game I played on
preview a while ago and I think I felt
bad for this but I think my biggest sort
of take away from it was wow this was a
lot better than I anticipated I thought
this was going to be a piece of garbage
turns out it's it's okay and you gave it
a eight out of 10 I gave it an eight I
too went into until dawn expecting hot
flaming garbage chef and had way more
fun than I anticipated I it is summer
sleeper hit and I'm actually really good
like why maybe I can understand it but
I'm kind of bummed out that Sony is not
throwing the kind of marketing support
behind that they should that came is
great yeah I'm a little bit surprised to
I wouldn't have been before I played it
though so maybe that's telling of why
they're doing that and I've got a bunch
of questions from folks via Twitter yeah
but first of all what are your sort of
main takeaways from one till dawn what
makes it fun what makes it better than
just another David cage pit point kick
the bottom or your slip step button more
polygons more motions um there are a lot
of them of motions and until done I so I
am on like the telltale games review
train like I'm playing all of their
games right now I've been playing all
their games and they do this thing where
they're like all right your narrative
choices affect the story but with
telltale games it's like okay you're
gonna make choices but you're still
gonna arrive at the same narrative point
until dawn still has those narrative
points that you have to hit and those
beats that you have to hit but in terms
of how the story goes you have complete
control over when and how and who dies
like at any time so you can complete
this game having everyone survive and
can also yes quote unquote complete this
game was having everyone died wait so I
can order this at any time well you've
been beginning of the game if I way no
way let's get this over with ideally so
there are throughout the story like
there are different opportunities for
each character to die there's one
segment with one character where she
could die in any number of I think it's
like four ways over like a 20 minute
people really depend if you miss
if you miss like one quick time event I
know it's great so sorry this might
still be okay yeah this isn't a spoiler
cuz this may all god oh that's awful
Roboto those two little intestines yeah
yeah we're just clinging on for dear
life because you can compete the game
and having that dude survive if you want
you can make in the mall survive you can
make them all die I won't tell you how
that's all you to find out but I press X
today yesterday press X to calm down
dear it's [ __ ] ya know the deer the deer
are a big thing ok big its a spoiler if
I mention it but it's like oh yeah don't
yeah ok crap ok here anyway well I would
ask you question right when I was
playing the first I paid me the first
three hours in this preview it felt like
up until then maybe there wasn't that
much in terms of people dying is it
after that stage that all the like
craziness starts to happen so you get
about an hour and a half into the game
and the carnage starts ok but there's
sort of like a the game sort of takes
its time to introduce the characters
tell you what kind of character check
the characteristics they have and what
their relationship is like with the
other characters and as you go through
the game in addition to dying you can
improve or destroy their relationship
with our characters they have like an
affinity meter mmm um but the and that
affinity meter actually matters there's
a give one example of how crazy and how
deep this narrative web is but there's
an instance where you can choose to
either have yourself harmed or a another
character of the female persuasion huh
to marry me not have a crush on you and
if you choose to harm yourself uh later
in the game she actually the way that
she talks to you is very different
should be like yeah you know thank you
for saving my life thank you for
whatever and there's an instance where
later down the line you're being chased
toward the house by this this My Thing
Thing and I she will actually appear and
open the door for you and pull you to
safety ok if you do not choose to save
her she doesn't quite know that you
didn't choose to save her in there in
one instant rice and and she says thank
you for saving me thank you for saving
me but if you didn't choose her the
character that you're playing as will
actually be like instead of being like
yeah no man i had to say to
save you he'll just be like yeah yeah
because he didn't pick to save her and
she's alive Wow so in the second
instance if you also don't choose to
save her you're in the same instance
running towards the house thing chasing
you she'll stand in front of the door
and just watch you get mutilate oh wow
Jesus it's critten and show like the way
she talks to is different the way she
behaves with you is different like like
all of those little choices do ripple
out and they can cost you or the
character of life cool it's very deep I
got a bunch of questions I want to get
into a basil Frank at red tie guy
frankly asks how much replay value is
there would you really want to play it
again once it's been completed I've
replayed it four times how are you
through here's yep why when I played the
little segment that I did I went back
immediately and did it again half out of
like you know oh I should see what this
also looks like but I actually like it
was like 11 at night I wanna [ __ ]
actually want to get into this and I
play it again Peter are you interested
in playing on till dawn Allah are you
founded like David cage type games no
I'm not but this game is sort of
intriguing because I do like horror
stuff and everyone is just raving about
this so I'm kind of like okay I guess I
really should play this busy as hell me
i think i'm gonna guess other boy you
could've let completed 10 times and all
the time you play more than that
probably more about here my god and next
question comes in from mattis mocha ash
it's my favorite part of show just
saying mattis mocha I'm just saying
people's Twitter's name's ash my tush
svk and does butterfly effect really
matter and do the choices you make are
they important in the future or is it
more like telltale games well you
already answered a question that again
read my review and the antagonist in
this game antagonists what okay what I
want to ask you is okay without getting
into like the spoilery stuff cuz it is
it does feel like there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on and there for a while it felt
like cabin and woodsy where I'm it was
almost like the game is trying to pick
which version of like evil it was trying
to get me well I only played like the
first whatever our two and a felt like
that so in between the levels do is he's
like conversations with this with the
psychology like I just which were my
favorite part I think of doing cuz in
between them he's like super breaking
the fourth wall like going up to you and
saying like
you enjoying your game and you know
which do you find more you know
terrifying any give you this collar
needles or spiders out of one sage if
you take too long with us he like like
jumps at you and goes why are you taking
so long I hardship yeah he gets in your
face and it's that actor guy that
everyone knows who nobody knows yeah i
forgot as me but I know who is how much
does that stuff bleed into the game does
it or does it not like done okay it in a
satisfying way yes sometimes it's little
ways like an antagonist coming after you
will either have like a gas mask or a
needle yeah it's like clown face Oh or
or the antagonists oh man or like
something well I'm trying not to spoil
it cuz he talking you have a manager
solid and until dawn phase we have him
nothing to offer can't wait for the
metal gear for the gears of war guide to
come on let's look at nobody gets it
Tom's wife thighs but like but like oh
I'm proud to give me examples on a
spoiler okay so one of the conversations
I think it's I think it's in chapter 5
so this is not spoiler for Sony's
guidelines so there is a there's a
there's an incident where the
psychiatrist is all right let's figure
out how you feel about all the other
characters and you're given a pictures
of each character and you have to pick
the head you're given pairs I remember
that and by choosing the ones that you
like the most out of each pair the game
determines who your least favorite
character is I bet we picked the same
person who's your favorite [ __ ] [ __ ]
girlfriend Jessica the one I'm sorry
wait no just wait we released though
Emily short hair the one who wouldn't
pick up the bags why was he wet look he
was right what a [ __ ] she's such such a
[ __ ] and she actually I I have played
four times and I tried to do was save
them all playthrough and I just killed
her I'm like no you're so annoying and I
can't deal with you so she's dead that's
great that's how I thought about as
always I was actually looking forward to
a situation in which I could have her
[ __ ] kit yeah it's an she can die in
like four different ways right crazy um
but the game determines who your
favorite characters are and it seems to
me based on what what I have played that
who your least favorite character is the
game keeps them alive longer because she
really really really hard to kill like a
like and I then I tried not picking her
and I tried picking um who was it
Jessica yeah it was really hard to kill
her and I think the game takes note of
who your favorite character is and then
just sort of like gives them more [ __ ]
to deal with that's amazing thank you
but with four players I've seen very
very like different stuff it's crazy
cool ah thanks very much for coming on
yeah that Alexa last question a lot of
people asking obviously with the
replayability it is good you can play it
again you're still talking about maybe
like 10 hours with two playthroughs does
it feel like a game that's worth sixty
dollars yeah for the amount of content
that's in it you just don't see it the
first time around in addition to the
story the story that you're given
there's all those clues you have to find
I mentioned them in my review but those
sort of shed light on the story and
sometimes not finding a clue means life
or death for certain people or certain
situations so there's a lot to it
there's no way you can see everything
the first time around and I definitely
think it's worth it if you weren't
reviewing it would you like to keep
replaying it though I think I see that's
the question on my mind because I know
people might play through it once and
think yeah I got this out of there right
but I spent 60 bucks for that my second
two places were after my review my life
yeah cool yeah and a satisfying our
satisfying in a different way problems
that's not gonna different wake someone
all I want to see this guide I might
spoiler like I just want like it's it's
fun it's actually your been fun is it
better than beyond two souls yeah Mary
also agrees there you go yeah oh great
thank so much going on eight out of 10
on gamespot com that's until dawn and
make sure you check out the review on
the site and let us know what you think
about the game and if you're hyped about
it in the comments below